the world will tell you a lot of things
it will tell you to think a certain way
to talk a certain way to act a certain
way don't do it it will tell you how
long to stay young for and when to grow
up when you can have fun and when to be
serious it will tell you what direction
to go what you should like and what you
shouldn't don't do it it will tell you
who you are and how to see yourself to
hide parts of who you really are
so you fit in better and don't cause any
problems you will tell you to give up to
do something different
to settle to accept don't do it it will
tell you to want a certain type of job
to work a certain amount of hours to buy
a certain amount of stuff to get married
by a certain age and own a certain house
and have a certain number of kids don't
do it
don't do any of it unless you have
thought long and hard about it and
decided that you want to do it or should
do it until you have truly and sincerely
decided that it's right for you that
there's no other way that might be
better for you because the world wants
to tell you the best way to live not
because anyone knows but because
everyone is a little scared that no one
really does and no one wants to go it
alone so collectively everyone decides
which way to go and how to live what the
template for life should be what the
standard route to travel is and
regardless of where it goes mostly
everyone agrees and blindly follows suit
so that it feels like everyone's in it
together which sounds nice but don't do
it
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder